-Guys, tonight is
our 1,500th show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In honor of that, something
special is about to happen.
Years ago, we had an idea
for a bit
called
"Straight Up Goes For It."
It was a simple idea.
We wanted somebody to come out
and straight-up sing
"Drops of Jupiter"
by the band Train.
That's it.
That's the whole idea.
This sketch has been
our white whale.
We've been pitching it
for years,
to dozens of people,
famous people that
you know and love,
both singers --
they sing in movies --
they dance, they sing, and
they actually have music out.
They all passed on it.
[ Laughing ]
But not tonight.
Tonight, that changes,
because we finally have someone
who has the guts to do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He doesn't play the piano,
by the way.
[ Laughing ]
And he doesn't even really
know how to sing.
But he's doing it
because he's cool,
and he's funny, and he gets it.
So now, ladies and gentlemen,
I present to you,
Kit Harington
Straight Up Goes For It.
[ Applause ]
[ "Drops of Jupiter" plays ]
♪♪
-♪ Now that she's back
in the atmosphere ♪
♪ With drops of Jupiter
in her hair ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ She acts like summer
and walks like rain ♪
♪ Reminds me that there's
a time to change ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
♪♪
♪ Since the return from
her stay on the moon ♪
♪ She listens like spring
and she talks like June ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ But tell me, did you
sail across the sun? ♪
♪ Did you make it to
the Milky Way ♪
♪ To see the lights all faded ♪
♪ That heaven is overrated? ♪
♪ Tell me, did you fall for
a shooting star? ♪
♪ One without
a permanent scar? ♪
♪ And did you miss me while ♪
♪ You're looking
for yourself out there? ♪
♪♪
♪ Can you imagine no love,
pride, deep-fried chicken? ♪
♪ Your best friend,
always sticking up for you ♪
♪ Even when you know
you're wrong ♪
♪ Can you imagine no first
dance, freeze-dried romance ♪
♪ Five-hour
phone conversation? ♪
♪ The best soy latte
that you ever had and me ♪
♪♪
♪ But tell me, did the wind
sweep you off your feet? ♪
♪ Did you finally get
the chance to dance ♪
♪ Along the light of day ♪
♪ And head back toward
the Milky Way? ♪
♪ And tell me, did you
fall for a shooting star? ♪
♪ One without
a permanent scar? ♪
♪ And did you miss me ♪
♪ While you're looking for
yourself out there? ♪
-♪ Na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na, na ♪
♪ And did you finally
get the chance to dance ♪
♪ Along the light of day? ♪
-♪ Na, na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na ♪
♪ And did you fall for
a shooting star ♪
♪ Fall for a shooting star? ♪
-♪ Na, na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na ♪
♪ And you're lonely
when you're ♪
♪ Looking for yourself
out there ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
Kit Harrington
Straight Up Goes For it!
You're the best, buddy.
Check out his episode
of "Modern Love"
on Amazon Prime Video.
We'll be right back to
talk with Kit Harington!
-♪ Na, na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na ♪
♪♪
♪ Na, na, na, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na ♪